j'ai l'impression qu'il appartient à
quelqu'un d'autre
ce bouclier représente un tas de choses
pour un grand nombre de personnes
[Musique]
les symboles ne sont rien sans les
femmes et les hommes qui leur confère
leur valeur
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un qui
ranime notre flamme
[Applaudissements]
tout est plus compliqué maintenant
on ne s'arrêtera pas
vous n'avez pas le droit de nous rejeter
tout le monde
vous pourrez plus faire machine arrière
a pas besoin d'aller à l'affrontement en
garde et ses seuls moyens
[Musique]
on n'a pas le droit de perdre
que ce soit clair
[Musique]
on va régler ça à notre manière
on est d associer décoller sans que ça
fasse de nous une équipe non
mais avoue qu'on a quand même la classe
[Musique]